all right why don't we get started
um today we're going to continue our
discussion of producer theory
once again to remember to put this in
context we the first few lectures were
working on consumer theory to help us
derive a demand curve
now working on producer theory to help
us come up with supply curve
we started last time by talking about
how producers profit maximize
and the profit maximization implies cost
minimization
uh that if you want to maximize profits
you're going to want to produce as
efficiently as possible
and basically to do that
we need to understand how your costs
vary with your output
if you're going to produce at an
efficient level you need to understand
how what your costs are going to vary
with your level of production
so essentially our goal of this lecture
is to develop a cost curve
develop a curve which tells you how the
cost of your production
varies with how much you produce and
that's what we're after in this lecture
okay so we're going to start in the
short way the short run
and then turn to the long run so start
with developing a short run cost curve
and then turn to long run
okay and to make this lecture sort of
mathematically coherent
throughout the whole lecture we'll work
with our favorite functional form
a production form of the function q
equals the square root of l times k
remember firms produce goods
little q using two inputs labor and
capital
labor is a variable input that means you
can change it in the short run
and the long run capital is a fixed
input
which means that you can only change in
the long run okay
so in the short run we're going to have
two kinds of costs
we're going to have fixed costs which
are going to come from a fixed level of
capital
and we're going to have variable costs
we're going to come from our labor so
we're going to have two kinds of costs
fixed costs they're fixed because in the
short run you can't change the level of
capital
and variable costs which are the costs
of our labor
of labor and then we're going to have
total costs are simply going to be fixed
costs plus variable costs okay
so that's how we think about costs think
about any the cost of a firm's
production
in the short run is the sum of their
fixed costs
i.e their capital costs and the variable
costs i either labor costs
now we're going to show you how you can
turn a production function
into a cost function
and to do so you simply need
to recognize that costs
the costs of firms production are simply
the amount of capital it uses k bar
times the price of that capital which
we'll call
r plus the amount of labor it uses
times the price of that laboratory we'll
call w the wage
okay this is the easy part think of the
amount of hours of work you use
times the wage per hour or the amount of
workers times the salary per year
in any case this is easy to understand
every additional unit of labor
comes with the cost that is the wage of
that unit of labor so think about an
hourly model
every hour you work at your convenience
store
they have to pay you the minimum wage
for that hour okay that's the
cost of that hour of labor capital is
harder
we call r the rental rate and the reason
is because
we don't think of don't think of buying
capital
don't think of buying a machine think of
renting a machine
the reason we do that is to make the
periodicity work okay
you don't buy a worker thank god you
rent that worker
and you rent that worker at a pr at a
price w
so when the firm uses your time they're
renting your time an hour at a time
at a price w when we get machines
think of a firm as renting machines for
a price
r per machine per time period okay
so i understand firms usually don't do
this they usually buy machines and we'll
come back
to even if you buy a machine how it
effectively is like renting it
but for ease of thinking about this want
to think about flows not stocks
so about the firm's decision as renting
a worker at the price wage
at the price w or renting machine the
price are yeah
all that would be in there and we'll
come back to that that's right this is a
this is sort of the
per period cost of using a machine this
is the per period cost of using a worker
is the wage this is the per period cost
of using machine
which will include all the costs of
running the machine as well as the cost
of
renting the machine itself okay
so later we'll talk about how you own
the machine and we'll we'll come back to
the fact that you can actually
our representation is not bad but for
now just think of renting machine or if
it's a building
think of this as the year as the rent
you pay on that building
okay not the cost of building them build
the building now
armed with our production function
okay and let's also say
to make life easy uh i did this wrong in
my notes so i hope my
the other teachers figure it out uh to
make life easy
let's say let's say that the rental rate
r we're gonna say is ten dollars
and the wage rate w is going to be five
dollars
okay now
armed with a production function if you
simply have the production function
and these two prices you can derive the
short run cost function
how do you do that well just look at the
math we know
that q equals square root of l times k
bar
okay in the short run l times k bar
okay so inverting that simply means that
l equals q squared over k bar
l equals q q squared over k
bar okay and that means
that costs can be written
costs can be written as 10
k bar the price the rental rate is 10
we have k bar amount of capital plus
5 q squared over k bar
okay that's our cost function okay i
just plugged in for l
and then i multiply plug that for l and
multiply by the wage rate w
which is five okay
so for example for a fixed level of
capital this is cost so for example
let's imagine our short run level of
capital is one let's imagine we have one
unit of capital in the short run just to
make the math easy
then that simply says that cost
equals 10 plus 5
q squared and that's our cost function
10 plus 5q squared we've just derived
the short run cost function
10 is the fixed cost component that
doesn't vary with the amount you produce
so there's no q part of this 5q squared
is the variable component
that varies with how much you produce so
the cost function is a fixed part
which comes the fact of one fixed unit
of capital
and a variable part which comes from the
fact that the amount of q
that the amount of q drives the amount
of labor we need
okay question about that math
all right now armed with this cost
function let's write that down again
here so c equals 10 plus five q c
equals 10 plus five q squared
that's gonna be our short run cost
function we're gonna work with and
remember
that short run cost function came
directly from that production function
to derive this equation all i needed was
that production function
and those two prices and i derived this
okay armed with that okay we can define
some of the key
concepts that will drive our entire
analysis of firms
and the single most important concept is
marginal cost
which is what it sounds like the
derivative of cost with respect to
quantity
okay so in this it's the marginal cost
is delta c delta q
okay that's marginal cost
okay we'll also care about average cost
which is just c over q okay it's very
important in this class to keep our
modules different from our averages
the average is simply over the entire
range of production what is the average
cost of producing each unit
the marginal is what's the cost of
producing the next unit
and since production functions are
non-linear those will not be the same
generally okay average will not equal
marginal in general
because of nonlinear function delta c
delta q is not the same as c over q
okay so we can actually graph these in
figure six one
figure six one shows the cost curves
for this cost function i just wrote down
which comes from that production
function
okay so you can see that the marginal
cost
as i said is delta c delta q well that's
10q
so the marginal cost the cost of
producing the next unit
rises with the number of units which
makes sense the cost is a q squared term
in it
so obviously the marginal cost can have
a q term in it
so basically the more you produce the
higher your marginal cost
the more units you produce the more
little q the higher marginal cost
average cost is this sort of funky shape
thing
where it's which is 10 over q plus 5q
i just divided this by two okay where
it's first declining
and then increasing why is that
why is average cost first declining and
then increasing
we'll see what just intuitively why is
that why in general in the short run
would we expect that
average costs first to fall and that
increase
you have ideas yeah
well no but it's falling first so why is
it why is it falling first you're
it's about that yeah really high average
or
first fixed cost right
right the first units are paying off
your fixed costs if you think about it
well the first units you sell
basically you start with this huge fixed
cost so actually
by selling two units yes you get the
variable cost second unit but you get to
pay off the fixed costs the first unit
so look at here on this graph we show
average fixed
costs and average variable costs average
fixed costs are 10 over q
if you only produce one unit your
average your average fixed cost is 10.
you produce units it's five with every
unit you produce your average fixed cost
is falling you're paying off that fixed
cost
average variable cost rises
every unit you produce you're getting
more and more variable cost
you put those together and you get a
function that first declines and then
rises
you first pay off your fixed costs so
your average costs are falling then your
marginal cost then you start to rise
because you've got
marginal cost that increases quantity
produced and critically
the marginal cost intersects
the average cost curve at the minimum of
average cost
and that's just mathematical okay if you
have any function
and you take the average then the
minimum is going to be at the derivative
okay that basically before you get to
here 1.5 units
before 1.5 units average cost
is above marginal cost because you're
paying off your fixed costs
once you get beyond 1.5 units average
cost is below marginal cost
so average cost hits marginal cost at
the minimum average
like cost yeah large company he
eventually
doesn't really have to worry about their
fixed cost because like if they're
having a lot more workers their entire
cost is going to be considered basically
in the short run
it depends on this function you said
large but large can be defined in two
ways
but absolutely true certainly if we take
this very function
for large enough q's average fixed cost
asymptotes to zero
right 10 over infinity zero so for large
enough q's the average fixed cost goes
away
okay in the short run remember we're in
the short of these fixed costs
okay now so other questions good
question other questions about that
so that's our basic intuition the short
run is that at first your costs are
super high
because you got to pay because you had
to build the plant okay
but then over time that plant cost falls
and then your only cost is based on that
you got to hire more workers if you want
to produce
more okay
now what we want to notice is that in
the short run
there is a really close relationship
one was the key relationship between
marginal cost
and the marginal product of labor which
we defined last time and the marginal
product of labor
was dqdl how much remember
digging a hole and diminishing marginal
product that each additional worker for
a fixed level of capital
is less and less productive right we
talked about that last time
well the marginal cost of production
is as i said equal to delta c over delta
q
okay well we know from last time
that delta q over delta l we defined as
the marginal product of labor
right plugging those um
and uh so we know marginal cost of delta
c delta q
okay and we can write this if you take
the derivative
of the cost function so our general cost
function up there see the cost function
at the top there
take the derivative of that with respect
to the amount of labor
well the first term drops out because
it's fixed
so you can rewrite delta c delta q as
w times delta l delta q
ah w times delta l delta q
right i just rewrote delta q delta w
got it's brutal sorry guys
w times delta l over delta
q okay a little bit better okay i read
that because i just took the derivative
of the cost function
okay first term drops out we take the
derivative second term i just took the
derivative here
or the discrete derivative and i just
said delta c delta q is w times delta l
delta q
well we know the marginal product is
delta q delta over delta l
so we can rewrite marginal cost as w
over the marginal product of labor
the marginal cost is equal to w
over the marginal product of labor and
that makes sense
the marginal cost of the next unit will
be higher
the higher the wage and lower the more
productive the worker
making another unit with a super
productive worker
is cheap okay make another unit with a
very unproductive workers expensive
so essentially the more you pay them for
each hour of work
the higher your marginal cost but the
less they get done each hour of work
the higher your marginal cost so that's
why
roughly speaking firms might want to pay
a lot to people who are high skilled
okay so you might say gee why are they
paying my friend twice what i'm paying
well maybe your friend's twice as
productive as you
okay that would make or two and a half
times productive as you and that makes
sense
so we can't just say that it's a mistake
to pay someone higher wages we have to
consider
their wages relative to how productive
they are
okay and that's a key relationship uh we
will um
we'll come back to okay
question about that all right
that's the short run now let's go to the
long run it gets a little more
interesting actually i was riding that
side i'll switch to this side today
switch things up
i guess i do decide i'd block you less
probably so i should do this side
okay long run cost curse
okay long run cost now here what gets
interesting
is now k is no longer fixed now we get
to choose our input mix
okay and now our goal is going to be
how do we choose our input mix
to minimize costs that's our goal here
how we're going to choose the mix of
workers and machines
to produce a given quantity most
efficiently
now that optimal mix may change with the
quantity
so we're going to start we're going to
say two steps first we're going to say
for a given
quantity picked out of a hat what's the
right
mix of labor and capital that minimizes
the cost of producing that quantity
given our production function then we're
going to say
as the quantity varies how does that
change the optimal mix of l and k
and does it okay so two steps first say
for a given quantity
what's the right l and k to minimize
cost producing that quantity
then ask well as we vary the quantity
how does l and k vary optimally
okay so basically
we want to find the economically
efficient combination
of l and k which is a combination that
produces goods
at minimum cost okay and to do this
we are going to write down to derive
this we're going to write down what we
call iso cost curves
iso cost curves remember last time we
did isoquants
which felt a lot like a difference
curves costs they feel a lot like budget
constraints
okay iso cost curves are essentially the
firm's budget constraint
okay they're essentially mappings of the
function
c equals wl plus rk
essentially mappings for different
amounts of k and l
of the function c equals rk plus wl
so if you look at figure six two here we
see our iso cos
lines okay so let's talk about this for
a second
so for example take the middle one the
hundred dollar iso cost
this is saying what combinations
of labor and capital cost you one
hundred dollars
well with a rental rate of ten dollars
and a wage of five dollars that means
you could have 10 machines and no
workers
or 20 workers and no machines or some
combination in between
okay this is just a budget constraint
it's just saying given the amount of
money you want to spend
given your cost okay how many machines
and workers can you have the difference
is
we don't start i didn't start this
example by saying your parents give you
x dollars
that's why firm theory is harder than
consumer theory i pinned down the
consumer theory problem much more easily
by saying your parents give you x
dollars
which told you which line to draft graph
i don't have that here i haven't told
you that here
so you have to graph the series of iso
cost curves because you don't know
what the optimal cost is going to be
that's going to be pinned down later
that's what makes supply theory harder
okay you have to draw the series so you
draw these series of
iso cost curves different combinations
that represent different amounts
different totals of cost
and of course the slope of that iso cost
curve
is delta k delta l
or minus w over r
okay that's the slope or in this case
minus 0.5
okay
now those you're thinking ahead i know
you guys are very insightful as a class
i'm sure some many of you think in your
head
might think gee that slope might not
that slope might change as the number of
workers and machines changes could you
imagine
the relative price of capital labor
changes in different costs and it might
and we'll put that aside for now
for now assuming for every relevant
quantity these prices
five and ten dollars are fixed let's
ignore them where those prices come from
they're just given now we'll come
back to that later okay like i said this
course is sort of like peeling an onion
we raise things then we come back and go
to the next layer of where'd that come
from
right now we're we'll tell you where w
and r come from
right now we're going to take them fixed
and we'll assume they're always five and
ten dollars regardless the amount
produced
okay now here's the question
you're a firm that wants to produce a
certain amount of units
you have a production function and a
cost function
how do you graphically figure out
the right combination of capital labor
to use to produce a certain amount of
units
yeah the
the the tangent between the isoquant and
the isocosta
that's exactly right just as i asked you
what is the right combination of pizza
and cookies
and you told me that it was the tangency
of the indifference curve and the budget
constraint it's the exact same logic
here
the optimal mix of capital and labor
comes from the tangency
of the iso quant with the iso cost as we
see in figure six three
and ignore the like somehow that curve
is sort of connected at the top it's
sort of a glitch a power point just
ignore that
it's not actually like a square or a
trapezoid it's just a curve
what would you call that the curve and
the two sides that uh
that's not trapezoid that's not that's a
it's not a polygon okay
it's just a line all right um so
basically
uh is there a name for that a curve in
two lines i don't think so
it's just a polygon right okay so it's
not a polygon it's just a curve
okay so the curve is the isoquant for
the square root of 12.5 what do i mean
by that
i mean that is the combination of
capital labor
that delivers square root of 12.5 units
of production
okay so what that curve is all possible
combinations
of capital and labor that deliver
square to 12.5 units
okay just like the indifference curve is
all possible combination of pizza and
cookie that leaves you equally happy
this is all possible combination of
capital labor that leads with
that leads you to a given production
level
and as we said the further out the
isoquant the more you can produce
so you want to produce as much as you
can given the prices you face in the
market
well those price you face in the market
are delivered by the iso cost curve
so the tangency is the best is the cost
minimizing point
that's when you're producing the most
you can given the cost you face in the
market
the most you can given the cost you face
in the market
okay and that tangency condition
once again continue our parallels to
consumer theory
that tangency condition is going to
deliver
that the marginal product um
is going to deliver that the marginal
product of labor
over the marginal product of capital
which we remember called last
time the marginal rate of technical
substitution
okay is going to be equal
to w over r actually the negative of
these is going to be equal to each other
but we'll just cross out the negatives
so the negative of mpl over mpk
which we call the marginal rate of
technical substitution is equal to the
negative
of w over r the slope
the optimal point is where the marginal
rate of technical substitution equals
the slope
which is the wage uh which is the wage
to rental rate ratio alternatively i
don't know if anyone besides me likes
this intuition
we can rewrite this as um
mpl over w equals mpk
over r my bang for the buck formulation
that i like
that the next dollar of wages
if you ask should i spend the next
dollar on wages or
machines you should do it until the next
dollar of wages
delivers you the same return as the next
dollar of machines
okay this is what you get for the next
dollar of wages mpl over w
this will get the next dollar machines
mpk over r you want to continue to
trade off machines and workers until
that condition is true
okay so let's actually now solve for
this okay for our for our example
let's actually solve for that
okay if we solve for this we know that
the marginal product of labor
which is dq dl
okay is 0.5 times k
over square root of k times l
and the marginal product of capital
which is dq
dk equals 0.5
times l over the square root 0.5 times l
of the square root of k times l
okay just just taking the derivative of
the all i did was take the derivative of
the production function
okay so therefore
putting these together we're going to we
know that marginal rate of technical
substitution
in this example is equal to minus k over
l that's not a general formula
okay that's just this example the
marginalized substitution is equal to
the
negative of the ratio of capital labor
we also know that the wage rate
we also know we want to set this equal
to the negative of the wage rate
i'm sorry the wage the wage rental rate
ratio okay
and we know that's negative a half then
we know that's a half
so because that's five and that's 10. so
we want to set
the margin technical solution to the
wage rate rental rate ratio which means
we set minus k over hell equal to minus
a half
or at the optimum okay
that means that um your labor
your capital at the optimum that means
the amount of capital
should be half as much as the amount of
labor
in this example we just solved for the
efficient combination of inputs
the efficient combination is the issues
kate
you should use capital to labor in a
ratio of a half you're just half as much
capital as used labor
okay so let me pause there and let's
let's talk about where this is coming
from yeah
does that mean that at any given place
of cost per
that's the graphic intuition let's come
to economics intuition
the economics intuition is the following
the production function delivers this
relationship that the marginal rate of
substitution goes minus k over l
in other words when you're producing
goods given this production function
you're indifferent between the next
machine the next worker that's just the
way his production function worked out
that one more machine delivers you the
same amount as one more worker
okay now i've just told you that
one machine costs half of one more
worker
so which do you want more of
no one machine delivers the same return
as one worker
you want more workers workers cost hash
machines
they're equally productive so you want
more workers
so the optimal amount of machines is
going to be half as many as the number
of workers
you want more workers because you're
indifferent look at that production
function
you're indifferent okay you don't give a
[ __ ] about l versus k
they're the same to you okay you're a
hard capitalist man
machine or worker you don't care but the
market's telling you
you can get a worker for half the price
of machine so you as a good cost
minimizing capitalist
get take twice as many workers as
machines
okay and that's the outcome that you get
here
questions about that
okay so that's basically um
what we do to to derive this now
what i want is take this and then derive
our ultimate goal which is what is the
long-run cost function
that's sort of what we why we started
this lecture what is the long-run cost
function let's do the math
we'll do the math in five steps step one
q equals square root of k times l
okay step two
we know from up there that k over l
equals w over r we derive that
right leading us to the conclusion that
k
leaves conclusion to k equals one half l
okay we just derived that
therefore we can rewrite q
we can rewrite q as the square root
of one half times l squared
just substituting in because k equals
one half l
therefore we can solve for l
is going to be square root of 2
over q
and k
is going to be square root of 2 over 2
over q
okay l the square root of 2 over q k
is square root of 2 over 2 over q
i'm sorry i'm sorry no not not over q
i'm sorry that's my bad
error error go back
should always look at my notes it's
square root of 2 times q
my bad l is square to two times q
okay and k
is square root of two over two times q
okay therefore
armed with this l and k we can rewrite
our cost function
so step five is that
the cost function given this stuff the
cost function
equals r times square root of 2
times q
i'm sorry r times square root of 2 over
2 times q plus w
times square root of 2 times q i just
plugged in
the optimal l and k into my cost
function
okay now i can plug in the 10 and the 5
to get c
equals 10 times square root of 2
times q and i'm done
i've just derived the cost function this
is what we came here for
this is what you got up this morning
wanting to see okay
you got this one you said i want to know
how does the cost of a firm vary with
the quantity it produces
and i've just told you this tells you
how the
the costs that you pay vary the quantity
you produce
and i did that by by deriving the
optimal mix of l and k you want to use
and then simply imposing the prices of
those two
and i get a cost function yeah
i'm sorry would you be adding the two
terms which two terms
oh yeah plus i'm sorry you're right my
bad that's a plus
thanks this is the most math i'll do in
a lecture all year you can be pleased to
know
that's why it's my least favorite
lecture yeah generally true
uh do you mean this particular
functional form
no this is all dependent on that
production function i wrote down what's
generally true is this
okay or actually k wouldn't be what's
generally true is just
c equals in the long run what's
generally true is c
equals wl plus rk okay that's what's
generally true
i just make but what i've showed you is
given three things a production all i
gave you was a production function
a wage rate and a rental rate
given those three things you can then
derive the cost function
okay given those three things you can
derive the cost function
in fact given two things you can derive
the cost function you could actually
derive the cost function given one thing
given just a production function to
drive the cost function as a function of
these input prices
okay so that is a lot of uh that's a lot
of results from one function from one
production function
okay now other questions about this of
the math i got wrong
sorry about that yeah
did you just repeat the three inputs
that you're using all i use somebody
somebody tell me what
what do you need to get the magical cost
function what three things do you need
yeah w and r and then q
no w-r-n what about q you need q but
what about what do you need w-r-n
the production function starting with
the production function that
mathematical equation
this mathematical equation w and r
i'm done everything i've done this
lecture comes from those three things
the math is hard and annoying we will
have you practice it
you will not like it okay it's just
it's just kind of what you got to do all
right i don't like it
you're not going to like it it's just
what we got to do to get to the more
interesting stuff
okay yeah
it's fixed in the short run the bar on
the it shouldn't see a bar in a k over
here that's all over here when it's
doing the short run
yeah r w in order to get to the fifth
step
like yeah i needed r and w well to
simplify
k is one that's
oh you're right that's a good point i
needed r w back here you're right it's a
good point
it's a good point but i still could have
done this whole thing as a function of r
w
if i wanted to if i wanted to really you
know screw up my math
all right okay so now armed with this
let's
talk about what happens when input
prices change
we talked about with consumer theory
what happens when the price of pizza and
cookies change
what happens when the price of labor and
capital changes
what does that do so let's talk about
changes in input prices
okay let's go to figure six four
and let's look at with the same
production function square to l times k
we're not changing our production
function
we're gonna change the wage rental ratio
so line the
the the um we have our initial
uh we have our initial line our initial
um
wage rental ratio which is
that basically um you have a wage rate
of this um but that but but but the
budget constraint
essentially that's flatter is our
original budget constraint the flatter
budget constraint is original
strength that's a budget screen with a
price of capital of 10 and a wage of
five
and that intersects our isoquant at
point x so we chose five units
um uh we chose five units of labor
now we have a new we chose five units of
labor and two and a half machines
okay that was our original this is sort
of a messed up graph but our original
intersection
was at point x the cost minimizing
combination that got
square root of 12.5 production was to
have five
workers and two and a half machines now
let's say the price of workers rises
to ten the wage rate rises to ten bucks
an hour
so now workers and machines cost the
same
what is now the optimal mix of workers
and machines
well graphically we know
we still want to produce the square root
of 12.5
so we want to stay tangent to the same
isoquant
okay so basically what we're saying is
this is as if we said to consumers
keeping utility
changed changed the price what do we
call that
remember we call that keeping utility
constant changing the price
anyone remember we call that this who
said that
all right raise your hand next time be
proud substitution effect
that's the substitution effect it's the
same idea here we want to know
for a given level of production what
happens is the price of the inputs
change
and so we shift along the isoquant from
point x to point y
and you'll see we choose a mix where we
use
fewer workers and more machines
and just as the substitution effect
is always non-positive
this shift as these as the wage rate
rises the price to go to the x-axis
rises
you will unambiguously use no more
and almost certainly less workers
okay and you can see that graphically
think about graphically you're looking
for the tangency between this curve and
the line
the slope of the line just got steeper
therefore you must move to the left on
the curve it's the same proof as we use
the substitution effect
why the substitution effect was always
non-positive
okay it's the same intuition here we use
for y a rise in the wage rate will lead
you to higher fewer workers and more
machines
guess what you just entered the debate
on the minimum wage
and you follow the minimum wage what do
people say well if you raise the wage
you have to pay workers they'll be
replaced by machines
that's this this is the math this is the
mathematical and graphical intuition
behind the debate on which which we'll
get into later in the semester
but the basic idea of that debate is gee
if you force firms to pay more to
workers
they're going to substitute towards
machines that's exactly right in theory
in practice there's a lot of
complications but this gives you the
theory of why people make that argument
yeah
so in this example only the like
only the wage for workers in this house
not the machine why would the
iso cost like not have the same
uh y intercept ah great point because
here i'm drawing
a new iso i am drawing the iso cost that
i would use
while still producing square to 12.5
so that's just the substitution effect
i'm just i i'm not drawing the full set
of iso costs at the new
price i'm just saying to produce the
same amount what's my new if i want to
produce the same amount
what combination i now have to use
okay yeah
the total cost of production let's see
it use yeah it has to be uh no
uh let's see no total cost doesn't have
to be the same the total cost used to be
five workers
at five bucks an hour that's 25. it used
to be 50.
now what is it it's now it's 70.
the total cost has gone up
exactly it's not like the budget income
is fixed that's what's hard about
producer theory
because basically the budget constraint
was sort of asking
you know keeping your budget fixed this
is like asking keeping your total
production fixed
and so now you have to pay more to get
to get that level of production
okay it's good questions okay now
hopefully what does this lead to
this so so that gives us our change in
input prices okay other questions about
that
now remember it's at the beginning of
the lecture we're first going to solve
for
what is the cost minimizing combination
of inputs for a given quantity
we derive that up there it's half as
much going back to our old prices
it's half as much capital as labor now
we want to ask
how does your cost change as the
quantity changes
and we call that the long run
expansion path
the long run expansion path which is how
do your costs expand
as you produce more and we see that in
figure six
five in figure six five we show the
particular case
of a linear long run expansion path
that's what you get in this example
it's a particular case what this case
says
is at any given level of production
the optimal mix of labor and capital is
the same
in other words you always want to have
given
essentially given the price of labor
is half the price of capital you always
want to have twice as many workers as
machines
so if you want to produce square to 12.5
you want five workers and two and a half
machines
if you want to produce square to 50 you
want 10 workers and five machines if you
want to produce square to 112.5
you want 15 workers and seven and a half
machines so the long run
given this production function the long
run expansion path is linear you always
want the same ratio
of workers to machines yeah
the reason why we don't necessarily have
a strict
budget per se
we can yeah a loan out this is what i
tried to say it's sort of i always say
every year but it's hard we have to come
back to it
the reason producer theory is harder is
because
we're not given a fixed constant we are
with consumers
consumers we're saying look you've got
an amount you've got a resource you've
got a constrained maximization
we haven't constrained their
maximization yet there's another
constraint we need
they have an extra degree of freedom
relative to consumers
now in fact consumers have degree of
freedom too when you grow up your
parents don't give you money you decide
how much to make so in reality consumers
you could do this will have the same
degrees of freedom
but we started with the easy consumer
theory case where you constrict we
we we took away a degree of freedom now
we're adding it back which you can
choose how much to produce
like you being able to choose your
income as a consumer okay and that
leaves the wrong
long run expansion path let me go on
because i want to make sure i get
through this stuff
okay now the long run expansion path
does not have to be linear
so think about look at figures 6 6 five
b and six five c
so six five b is a long run expansion
path
for a production function such that
capital becomes less productive the more
you produce
i don't have the example the production
function but you write down production
functions
which have the feature that the more you
produce the less productive capital
becomes
the less each edition you have capital
helps we'll teach this unit of workers
okay so you know we could think of this
roughly as sort of like a fast food
restaurant
that kind of you know each addition that
basically there's so much stuff to do
where workers can efficiently share
tasks and things these distal worker
that the marginal product of labor
essentially diminishes less quickly than
the marginal product of capital
okay on the other hand in figure 65c
we can have a long run expansion path
where where labor becomes less
productive relative to capital
i think it's like heavy machinery where
like basically all workers can do is run
the machine
so that second worker workers don't
really do much but sit there and flip a
switch
you need the worker to flip the switch
that's all they do so the second worker
that you're already flipping the switch
so really adding more machines is a more
productive way to expand
expand output none of these is right or
wrong
we're just saying that this shape of
this expansion path
can basically vary with how much
uh with different production functions
okay
but they're all the same idea
now so basically
that tells you um and the bot but here's
the bottom line that we want to come to
that long run expansion path
is our long run cost curve
so ultimately if you want to ask
how do my costs vary with how much i
produce
this curve tells you because what it
does it says for every level of
production i'll tell you the optimal
combination of l and k
given the price of l k that will tell
you the cost
and so you trace out the cost with every
level of production this is your cost
curve
this long run expansion path tells you
what the costs are for every level of
production
and it tells you that because you've
made you're doing the efficient level of
production
okay that's what the long expansion pass
telling you okay this is hard
i'm about to make it harder which is
we're now going to talk about the
relationship
between short run costs and long run
costs
okay and the key insight
is that long run costs are everywhere
lower than short run costs without
looking to figure because the figure
doesn't help with this
why does that make sense why are long
run costs
why if you can optimize over the long
run
will you always have costs that are no
higher and in general lower
than optimizing the short run
yeah you've already had the right
capital
because you have an extra degree of
freedom i think this le chatelier's
principle is that right for the chemist
among us
that basically like essentially an extra
degree of freedom
means the more you can optimize over the
better you can do in optimizing
in the short run you could strain by the
size of the building in the long run you
can choose so let's to see that
let's go to figure six six
this is a confusing figure so bear with
me as i walk you through it
okay consider a firm with three possible
sizes of plants
they're going to build a plant so the
capital here is the building
and there's three possible sizes small
medium and large
okay the small plant
has the curve srac1
what does that curve mean that means
that the small plant
i'm sorry small plant is srec1 the
median planet is srac2
and the large planet has srac3 compare
srac1 to srac3
what this is saying is for small
quantities of production
srac1 lies below srac3
right for small quantities of production
if you extend srac3 out
you see it levels of production like q1
or
even q2 srac3 is way above srac1
when you go to level of production like
q3
srac1 if you extend that dash line out
it's going to be much
much higher than srac3 so the right
an srac2 is in between so essentially
for different levels of production
these give the different optimal short
run cost curves
in the long run you get to choose
so the long run average cost curve is
the lower envelope
of the short run average cost curves
because in the long run you say
well here's my production level i know
in the long run
so if i know i'm going to build a lot of
things i choose srac3 i choose i choose
the biggest plant
if my own production is going to be low
i choose the smallest plant
but i can optimize in the long run by
choosing the right size plant for my
production level
this is hard and i'm almost out of time
so let me end with an example that
perfectly illustrates this
tesla elon musk everybody's favorite guy
these days
okay tesla when they came out
had to decide how big a plant to build
how many batteries to make batteries are
the key and put it teslas
okay and they expected to make to have
demand for 20
000 cars by the year 2017.
so they built a plant like srac1
they built a plant that was the
efficient plant to produce 20
000 cars the problem is the man was for
200 000 cars
as a result there's a three year waiting
list to get teslas
it turned out that was not the right
size to produce they lost money
relative to the author they made money
musk is incredibly rich but they didn't
do what was most efficient given the
underlying demand
but now musk can reoptimize
now he's saying wait a second people
want way more cars
well producing them at the tiny plane
was exorbitantly expensive i had to run
it over and over time
pay workers overtime to produce 200k
cars that tiny plant just was
exorbitantly expensive
that's if you take that dashed line and
said it way the hell up the srac1 line
extended way to hell up but incredibly
expensive so what is musk doing now
building the largest battery plant in
the world
in nevada he is building a battery plant
that can produce batteries for 500
000 cars so we shifted from srac1 to
srac3
he's now saying in the long run i can
more if i'm going to produce 200 000
cars i can do that more efficiently
with a giant battery plant and that's
what he's doing
so he's reoptimizing now what if musk is
wrong
what if it turns out teslas suck and
people like i don't want them anymore
someone else
or you know chevy finally figures it out
makes a good electric car
okay then what's gonna happen is he's
gonna have a mistake in the long run
then the third period he'll go back to a
smaller plant again
but he always can do what's efficient in
the long run given the underlying demand
so tesla is an example of this sort of
long-run short run
dichotomy anyway it's a lot of stuff for
one lecture we'll come back next time
talk more about costs and then we'll
start getting into competition
you